welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what happens
when chernobyl style radiation tidal
waves happen
over and over but to the marvel
cinematic universe
sure some superheroes are boring but
others make new jersey
pads to bang their robot corpse
boyfriends get the light
goo i'm eric boss here with me is tommy
bechtoldz
hey bro man i love summer and jersey how
are you eric oh
it's so nice the weather is warm there's
a neighborhood you wander into
and you lose your personality and you
shift decades based on the whims of a
sandy blonde woman well that's what
happens when uh you know your
neighborhood in new jersey is under a
bunch of power lines there's that weird
kind of radiation
and who knows what kind of sex cults
will come out of it remove
your clothes you're stepping over a line
now you're stepping over line you know
you are
yeah i mean it can't be worse than what
snooki did right like they can't
they can't be worse than what that those
guys got into it can't get weirder
i don't think oh i hope we get a jersey
shore episode of one division before
this season's over
please yes well one division is once
again
like many mcu titles trying to ground
this universe
in science by suggesting that westview's
witchcraft
is actually a kind of radiation but you
know this is not the first time
radiation has been used to explain the
whole madness
of the mcu so tommy what's our big
question this week america i'm glad you
asked since you seemed so confident
about this
how exactly has radiation from the
infinity stones affected the mcu now we
got this question from various
discorders
dark mosh tyler edwards actually
sauceless
and virtually sauceless i made that one
pretty much sauceless mostly sauceless a
lot of our friends on discord who are
all patrons who support this channel
have been asking this in various
different forms we figured we kind of
just like talk about
the radioactive effects that the
infinity stones and one division is
having on the mcu
and uh if you want to get your question
featured on bigquestion really becoming
a patron
and joining our discord is the the most
direct and easiest way to do it
it's where we always check first it's
where really the best questions tend to
be asked anyway
where all the action is now we thought
we were done with the infinity stones
after avengers end game but
the radiation those stones emitted
remains
tommy you may remember the moment in
avengers end game where bruce banner
said that the radiation is quote
mostly gamma uh and he compared it to
his
own origins with gamma radiation he's
like
i was made for this
is he rocky balboa
it was pretty great when i first got
here most of you people
didn't like me very much
but if i could gamma radiation and you
can get a radiation maybe we can
all get camera radiation and this
happened right as bruce banner snapped
everyone back and traumatized a ton of
hospital patients and workers as we
learned in one division not all good
things came from that
let's talk about what gamma radiation is
in the real world
it ain't fun um so gamma radiation as
opposed to
alpha radiation beta radiation is the
most powerful it is caused by weightless
photons emitting from unstable atomic
nuclei
you know i don't speak spanish in
english please so
uh those photons can pass through most
materials since they're
basically an electromagnetic wave that
they can go through anything
they're usually stopped by a couple feet
of concrete um but if they were to
contact
human tissue directly they destabilize
your dna
it's ugly it's not fun watch chernobyl
on hbo and you'll see what we're talking
about
in fact it's so dangerous that even when
the radioactive origin
substance of that game of radiation is
removed the irradiated materials that
came into contact with continue to emit
their own
radiation as photons from those
destabilized atoms continue to beam
out so using this logic to the mcu
even though the infinity stones may have
been reduced to atoms
the present day in the timeline their
effect lingers
ooh like a bad penny or a great
cranberry song oh did you have to
did you have to you have to let it
linger
oh it's so good takes you back but
interesting choice of words from bruce
banner he said
mostly gamma not 100
gamma that would suggest that there are
other types of radiation emitted by
those stones and that
is where wanda vision comes in see
episode four
made a point to describe the westview
anomaly as cmbr
cosmic microwave background radiation we
love a good sci-fi term or physics term
whatever it is an acronym uh we feel
like we're learning
it's a little it rolls off the tongue a
little nicer than bar just a bit
i mean depending on what you're eating
barf could roll right off that tongue
it could fly off that tongue it could
shoot out over the tongue
or just like a an olympic long jumper
just go right over the tongue
yeah yeah over the tongue under the
shirt that's what that was my rules
grandmother's house
[Laughter]
now cmbr is a real thing it's actually a
super faint electromagnetic radiation
and it exists everywhere thus
background uh and it's considered to be
proof that the big bang happened
that's why they're saying it's a relic
of the big bang it uh it's kind of like
everywhere it's faint it's always there
it's what causes static
on a tv screen that's what cmbr is and
that's kind of why they're linking it to
wanda vision but in episode 4 they cite
the big bang and that's a very big deal
because it suggests this historical
connection to the infinity stones in the
mcu
because in avengers infinity war wong
explained that the six stones
were produced by the big bang itself the
dawn of the universe
there was nothing then boom
big bangs and six elemental crystals
hurtling across the virgin universe oh
wong we miss you buddy we want to hear
that guy explain
everything in the mcu he just got away
and then go watch him on marco polo
where he just has sex with like 80 women
he cleans up
wasn't he also in the martian yes oh
he's great yeah okay
just walk into a room start talking i'm
listening now we also know that one
division is revisiting wanda's origins
with the mind stone right we've seen
uh footage of that scene where it's
floating in front of her we're going
back there we're gonna get some more
answers there
but by doing this the mcu is linking i
think
all of the anomalistic freak occurrences
really to these six stones that appear
during the big bang
so let us remind ourselves of everything
the mcu is essentially saying
was caused by infinity stone cosmic
radiation
so the first thing we're going to talk
about uh in relation to one division the
mind stone
activated the powers of the maximoff
twins wanda and pietro
is it the full source of their powers no
they might have had an x gene they might
have been born with that mutant gene
but the mind stone is what woke it up
it's kind of part of the formula
that infinity stone radiation activated
this gene in their dna
and this happened shortly before the
uh mind stone basically created vision
it's one of the five
components of vision tommy and i did
this in a past episode uh the big
question
it's one of those ingredients basically
what the mind stone brings
is not necessarily the brain because the
os comes from jarvis
right but it does um fuse it all
together in a way giving him a sort of
cosmic insight like jarvis didn't have
uh
that personality that was so
introspective and philosophical
that whole debate with ultron at the end
of age of ultron i think that was that
was the mind stone talking
yeah it's like fairy dust deep
introspective fairy dust
like cocaine people say i make too many
cocaine references so
we'll cut that one out no we're going to
double it too real
double down on it tommy cocaine bechtold
but most important for
wandavision is this idea that like that
mind stone at least in the mcu
seems to be kind of the link between
wanda and vision
and the fact that it's playing such a
big role in one division tells us that
you know the source of their connection
the fact that both of them are kind of
superpowered from the same
inglet that might be the kind of
representation of their shared heart
or their shared soul comes from that
infinity stone which is kind of a sad
thing it's like well if this gem gets
destroyed we get destroyed
it's like uh those necklaces that you
used to share with your best friend the
lockets where you get a half and i get a
half and if it gets destroyed
your parents have to move out of state
and then you go to iowa and you play
little league baseball there and i never
see you again
is that because you're a ghost because
all baseball players in iowa are ghosts
and cornfields
yes i saw a movie now uh another
important infinity stone giving
radioactive powers the space stone uh
that's what gave carol danvers her
powers
because in the captain marvel film that
cree slash scroll lightspeed engine
had radiation derived from the space
stone and that's what erupted
and washed over carol danvers basically
cooking her flesh but not her flight
suit interesting
a lot of interesting um inconsistencies
with the tesseract in that movie it's
able to be contained by
a happy days lunch box but it slips
through the hull
of an airplane in the first captain
america movie
you know science science is a tricky
thing
science if you put a question mark it's
a failsafe for whatever you can get away
with anything as long as you put a
question mark at the end
now while we're talking about the space
stone the space stone was also
instrumental in
teleporting red skull to vormir
and a lot of people believe that the
space stone since it has
similar properties of the bifrost that
the asgardian bifrost
may have had its technology derived from
that same space stone
it kind of looks like it's a big beam of
light that just transports you to the
heavens
so could those two be linked we know
that odin had a
ancient uh possession of the tesseract
before he was depicted bringing it to
norway
and we saw in that children's book in
the first thor movie he walked across
the rainbow bridge to do it
so is there some kind of historical
connection there we'll see now the power
stone of course from the first guardians
of the galaxy movie destroyed ronan the
accuser
nearly destroyed the guardians of the
galaxy 2. a lot of radioactive
it looked like kind of the same thing
made your flesh look kind of cooked
cooked flesh it's keto but it's not
uh it's not good you're ringing that
dinner bell for army hammer character
hey let's let's let's let the public
decide on army hammer guys give him
another chance
i'm a public i'm part of the public i
think the guy's a cannibal
he's probably a monster now most famous
use of infinity stone radiation of
course thanos snapping his fingers
pissing off thor who didn't aim for the
head and
uh half of all life was dusted and
i kind of want to run through the dusted
names because this list keeps growing
and
empty you in fascinating ways so we know
the names wanna max small peter parker
doctor strange bucky barn sam wilson
peter quill groot drax mantis t'challa
and then nick fury and maria hill we saw
all of that
in the final minutes of avengers
infinity war
but we also found out uh shuri
and we know that eric selvig and jane
foster
we saw in the post credits and the wasp
hank pym
hope van dyne janet van dyne uh we could
tell based off of the context from the
spider-man movies that mjnet
and flash and we think aunt may we also
have been told through the script that
yeah we mentioned jane foster and wong
were were included in the snap victims
uh we've been led to believe that sharon
carter and secretary
ross uh were were dusted as well
hawkeye's family we saw at the beginning
of end game
and then as of one division monica rambo
was dusted as well causing lots of drama
with her missing her mother's death
that's very sad
yeah and then shortly after this thanos
uses six stones again
to uh atomize the stones themselves
and this is what released that shock
wave of radiation that
rocket raccoon sensors picked up so it
kind of showed us that
this interesting shock wave of radiation
spills across the universe making us
think
does that do other things and then just
wrapping up other known uses of the
stones
and their radiation uh hulk brought
everyone back
who had been dusted but that radiation
badly injured his arm
and then meanwhile it freaked out monica
rambo and millions of people around the
world
and midtown high created a blood feud
between the basketball team and the
marching band
a lot of problems a lot of problems
unsolvable problems that will last for
generations
once you've with the marching band it's
over now the six stones combined were
used by tony stark to wipe out thanos
and his forces so that killed thanos 70
mile proxima midnight corvus glaive all
remaining out
riders and leviathans another infantry
but also that radiation
fatally injured tony stark himself so
those are the
uses of the radiation that we know about
but if this radiation persists what are
some other possible side effects that
are not
yet confirmed but appear to be on the
horizon well one
is this west view anomaly as it has come
to be known
in wanda vision so darcy lewis confirmed
that energy field to be composed of cmbr
dating back to the big bang and that the
radiation is probably coming from
wanda's
own sorcery which was derived from a
cosmic infinity stone so that's a big
deal
um we don't quite know yet if you're
watching this video after one of visions
episodes are finished you might be able
to tell us
more we're recording this halfway
through the season
uh it seems like other kinds of
anomalies like that
in the right set of circumstances in
this case is a perfect storm involving
wanda maximoff when she's particularly
heartbroken over losing vision
uh trying to access some of her own
inner witchcraft
yeah that uh combine that with other
people whose powers are derived from
infinity stones
that radiation just lingering all over
the galaxy all over the universe
other things like this could start
happening now um we should also talk
about with one division monica rambo aka
spectrum i'm pretty certain we are
looking at a spectrum
origin story you know uh when monica was
ejected from west view i don't know if
you saw this tommy
wanda's red glow continued to snake and
cover her body
was that uh carol danvers
infinity stone um energy radiation
moment
a level up for monica
now the side effect most people are
asking about is with mutants
so if wanda's energy field continues to
grow wider and wider
could it warp the anatomies of others
across the universe
or maybe rewrite reality in a way to
incarnate
mutants into existence kind of like a
reverse house of m as we've
talked about before a a very marvel
studios thing to do is like take the
thing in the comics and reverse it
and have that be how it happens uh
because it's just enough of a nod to the
comics without making it completely
loyal to the comics and
it frees you to do whatever you want
then with the characters
i think it's gonna have to be something
like that i like it's gonna have to be a
big event that creates a lot of mutants
right like that's gonna
yeah that's gonna have to be the
explanation as to why wolverine didn't
come save the world
when uh you know didn't help us defeat
thanos unless he did in some other
universe the other thing i
right the other theory i i think is the
bring them from another universe
is the other one that appeals to me yeah
that's that's possible and then if we
are getting more chris evans captain
america movies
if he's gonna be playing a young version
of himself it's probably gonna be set in
that alternate timeline that he lived
his life out in
and then maybe see some of those
rejected concepts from the first captain
america movie of like
they were going to put uh james howlett
in one of those pow camps
in world war ii and he was going to be
there i think magneto is going to be
there too
wow wow but of course there's also the
not as exciting option with mutants that
like they were there we just
the camera wasn't pointed at them you
know like there was some other side
mission that
uh logan was there for during world war
ii he just you know
he wasn't hanging out with the avengers
[Music]
now another possible radioactive side
effect the fantastic four
oh yes because specifically in episode
four of one division hayward said that
half of his astronaut pilots disappeared
in the blip
and that a lot of the others lost their
nerve uh to return
and it sounds like you know maybe not
all have reported back if astronauts
went missing
in space at the time of the snap that's
a very big
deal where did they go how did they come
back safely
uh that sounds like it could be the
origin story of
the you know members of the fantastic
four and victor von doom
you know maybe somehow through that
passage they get uh crossed through the
negative zone
or uh my theory has been the quantum
realm and the mcu is going to be
you know retconned as a negative zone
either way you know just missing
astronauts that's kind of like when you
hear that
in the marvel world it's like ah that's
our fantastic port i got very excited
when you brought up missing astronauts i
immediately got my fantastic four
antennas
yeah put up your posters a kind of a
bummer uh possible side effect is what
the possible side effect of all
radiation is cancer so
i bring this up because uh monica's
mother maria was being treated for
cancer at the time of the snap and
despite the test coming back clear her
doctor said that the cancer returned a
few years later
there's a lot about cancer we don't know
often cancer does come back
but is there going to be a reason for
that could lingering
radioactive gamma rays just
around the universe be what gave
maria rambo her cancer when it came back
we also know that cancer is going to pop
up uh with jane foster that's gonna
it's confirmed the thor love and thunder
is gonna feature the
the jane foster as a cancer patient
story arc where did that cancer come
from
um is it just gonna be like are we gonna
have a lot of different stories with
characters getting cancer in the mcu are
they all gonna be connected
yeah that's i hope not you better not
you better not
yeah i mean either way characters are
getting cancer and this isn't the only
other time this has happened
meredith quill died of brain cancer and
that was uh
you know ego gave her that brain cancer
he kind of like
uh killed off the loose threads of his
uh universe wide
fest
[Music]
but uh there might be some link with the
infinity stones in the celestials right
ego's
celestial his son peter quill was able
to wield an infinity stone and that was
a big mystery at the end of the first
guardians of the galaxy how is he able
to do that we found out guardians of the
galaxy vol 2
it's because he's the son of the
celestial so the celestials have a
certain infinity stone cosmic
radioactive coating
is that what allowed ego to across
galaxies
beam cancer into someone's head and is
that all coming from the same stone
radiation i like the idea of like a
plating over you that keeps you
you have a celestial layer i want a
celestial layer
i just want that as a layer on my bean
dip right like oh i got
the refried beans cheese oh sour cream
and a bit of celestial there yeah very
nice
tommy as we wave our geiger counter over
the mcu and trying to detect where
radiation is and how it's going to
affect things
one division is very clearly
reconnecting with the traumatic events
of avengers end game specifically the
trauma of the avengers reversal of the
snap and it
tells us that the mcu considered end
game to be a crucial watershed moment
that they
aren't done with they're gonna use to
set up all kinds of bizarre side effects
in phase four and beyond and i think
radiation is the key to all of it
bam we're gonna continue with some bite
size questions that tommy's gonna answer
us but first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
starting with our friends at
honey thanks to honey for sponsoring
this episode
we all shop online and we've all seen
that promo code feel just
taunt us at checkout like you want to
put something in me
oh you don't know you don't have
anything
oh bye bye enjoy paying full price
well thanks to honey that annoying voice
gets silenced forever
because honey searches for coupon codes
they make manually searching for those
coupon codes a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
then applies the best one it finds to
your cart
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
they range from sites that have tech and
gaming products to popular fashion
brands and even food delivery
when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click
apply coupons and honey searches for
coupons for that site
and if it finds one you will watch those
prices drop
off screen producer zack has used honey
to save seven dollars on a non-stick pan
and editor john used honey to save five
dollars on a fancy water bottle
honey has found its over 17 million
members over
two billion dollars in savings
and if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on all
these free savings it's literally
free and it installs in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid
and supporting this show get honey for
free at joinhoney.com
big question that's joinhoney.com big
question we also want to thank babel for
sponsoring this episode
uh oh in case you don't speak french
that was a poorly pronounced
ego killed meredith i'm working on my
accent
i'm working on it with babel the number
one selling language learning app
babel has made the language learning
process addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons when i
visited japan i couldn't speak a lick of
the native language so
when i'm able to travel again i want to
be better prepared babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go
like while you wait in line or while
you're doing your laundry babble designs
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind things you'll use
in everyday life
babble lessons were created by the over
100 language experts not some clunky ai
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
start your new language learning journey
today with babel
right now when you purchase a three
month babble subscription you will get
an extra three months for free that's
six
months for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use the promo code
big question that's b a b b e l
dot com code big question for an extra
three months free
babble language for life language for
life
learning no one else is for life nwo
baby
now comes the time for some bite size
question that tommy's going to answer
are you ready tommy yes
all right our buddy actually sauceless
is back
and they're double dipping on actually
sauceless
you double dip the chip they ask with
deadpool becoming
mcu cannon is deadpool's time travel
mechanic the same as
end games time travel no no it's not
okay avengers end game tries to stick to
the alternate timeline rules of time
travel or what eric calls
type 2 in which significant changes to
the past cause reality to split into
alternate histories
well the past timeline remains unchanged
so when endgame does time travel it's
basically creating several alternate
histories it's what back to the future
part
two uh expands on the future mythology
of
uh basically once you change things uh
you just create another history
and you create history after history
after history whereas the one that you
left
stays exactly the same you don't see a
weird thing where it's like
things uh cross dissolve and history
gets adjusted that doesn't happen in
this verse just another
tentacle in the octopus of time
uh all right deadpool 2 uses a more
comical ethnic approach to time travel
eric's type 1
in which time travel isn't meant to have
actual causal impact
on the universe and instead plays out
more like a cartoon
i mean it's deadpool come on deadpool or
cable go back in time it's implied to
have a
do-over effect time doesn't branch into
separate timeline
everything stays within one history that
gets warped by different choices
by the time traveler deadpool's time
travel mechanic isn't even consistent
with the time travel of his own universe
right the days of future's past featured
consciousness
time travel type seven in which kitty
pride
projects logan's conscious mind into his
younger body in the past and who hasn't
had that happen
what yeah well and tommy i want to thank
you for sticking to
our uh numbered types because let's just
make that a thing
i i want the i want to be the way that
the bechdel test i think is named after
you
yeah and what the boss test of time
travel is like does it do this then it
is type one does it do this then it is
type two uh i invented the bechdel test
but because i thought it was too
controversial for a man to have invented
it
i changed the spelling of it and and
credited it to a woman
that's the title
who was great on the simpsons this
doesn't mean that when deadpool
joins the prime mcu time travel won't be
the explanation
deadpool is a cartoon he's ridiculous he
can use
whatever logic he wants to arrive in
this world and we'll go with it because
it's dead
for sure because he's going to say
something quippy and it's going to be
funny and snarky and it's going to be
charming and we're all just going to go
god he's funny maximum effort and easy
on the eyes
uh the mcu might imply that fox's x-men
universe was one of the
many alternate timelines across a time
stream all monitored by the tva
it's possible that deadpool's time
jumping at the end of deadpool 2
made deadpool a person of interest to
the tva
and that could bring him into the mcu
multiverse
yeah i see i could say it'd be very
possible i mean remembering the end of
deadpool 2
it was that share if i could turn back
time
and he goes back any and he uh saves
vanessa he prevents
x-men origins with the wolverine from
happening
he prevents uh himself from doing the
green lantern movie
i think he tries to kill baby hitler uh
so all this stuff is like he's just
trying to change his own history but
it's so silly it's a joke it's like bill
and ted
and like the fact i think deadpool could
just like you know imagine owen wilson
and loki being like oh there's this
other guy wade wilson and
cable was just yeah you know and then
and then you know
wanda burped and then caused all these
to come together and then
he's just in the mcu now it's that
simple i hope it's that simple i don't
want to think about it too hard
no okay so uh civilian from discord
asked
is agent carter mcu cannon okay
agent carter is canon in the same way
that agents of shield
is which is to say that it it kind of is
agent carter follows peggy carter in the
late 40s in her early years establishing
shield avengers end game gave
agent carter's canonicity a big boost by
featuring james darcy as edwin jarvis in
the 1970s
the same actor who played jarvis and
agent carter yeah that was a big deal
it's like whoa
so they are for once acknowledging these
shows
however the mcu going forward on disney
plus has been extremely reluctant to
acknowledge agent carter
or agents of shield as part of the mcu
cannon especially as later seasons of
agents of shield really started to pull
away into alternate timelines
uh there was that thing in uh the final
season of agents of shield spoiler one
if you haven't seen it yet but they do
do some time travel and they do justify
it by saying they went through
quantum tunnels in the quantum realm uh
and they actually
make more sense out of the end game time
travel logic than endgame did
but uh it remains to be seen if the
um prime mcu is going to acknowledge
any of that as being part of their world
okay also episode three of wandavision
features an ad for hydra
soak which seems like a big nod to agent
coulson's rant about hydra mind control
soap
in the framework episodes of agent of
shield that blue soap everyone uses
hydra loads it up with chemicals it
seeps into our bloodstream
and plants false memories into our
brains yeah that was cool to see
but a nod it might have just been a meta
thing we don't know yet if like
hydra soap uh does actually exist rather
than just being like a parody projection
of westview unfortunately until we get
clarification from fiji
we can't consider agent carter formal
canon required viewing
yes by god yes please formal required
viewing and definitely
more canonical than the marvel netflix
series i think if you
consider canon in the mcu as like a
flowing amoeba
or a multi-tiered uh pizza pie or
something
you have like the main everything that
kevin feige produced like all the movies
in the the marvel disney plush shows
and then outside of that you have uh the
marvel tv
stuff that kevin feige initially gave
the okay to in the joss whedon
produced so that would be agents of
shield and then agent carter
a lot of the same actors appear in those
pretty much all the same actors
uh and then a broader tier from that you
have
the other things so you have like um the
runaways
you have uh daredevil punisher jessica
jones luke cage
uh iron fists uh they all kind of exist
uh broader from that
and then that's all contained within the
mojo verse
yes runaways is an interesting one
because it was only ever on hulu right
yeah it was only on hulu and it has a
lot of like marvel things in it
it has like a manure it has a dark hold
and then i think the gifted might be
part of that too the gift he's gonna say
let's not disrespect the gifted
shout out to steven moyer yes one more
question from colonel hogan on discord
who asked
how are they called x-wings and y-wings
in star wars if there's no
latin alphabet in star wars
colonel hogan you sneaky cheeky devil
when george lucas originally conceived
star wars the in-universe written
language of arabesh had not yet been
invented
so in the original cut of a new hope
english printed words using roman
letters were visible
however these were re-edited into
arabesh for the 2004
dvd release always tinkering george
always
always changing lucasfilm story group
had pablo hidalgo
considers roman alphabet characters part
of star wars canon the way many have
justified this is by calling it the high
galactic
alphabet i like that
a snobby alternate written language
that's identical to the roman alphabet
so that would explain the existence of
roman letters in the names
of the x-wing and the y-wing there's
also the language of tunisia
which corresponds to the real world
greek alphabet alphabetical delta
epsilon z8 eight eighth article into
munizai omicron oopsilon phi kai sci
omega
iota forgot those two thus
why we have a lambda class shuttle oh i
see yeah the lambda ta
class yeah okay so that would be greek
okay there's an answer for all of these
things i'm sure
it's really just because they didn't
think to do it you know agree yeah they
look like x's they look like y's that's
how the
the production designers classified them
and they're like that's just what we'll
call them you can tell that it's an
x-wing because the way it is but good
thing the story group has an answer for
us
and thank you tommy for giving us that
answer hey my pleasure my treasure
oh we have time for one more box scratch
question and this comes to us from mj on
discord
who asked if you were in inception what
would your totem be
you know eric uh i my totem
would be when i was a young performer
when i was a young
los angeles i was uh taking a workshop
at second city
on hollywood boulevard and i was leaving
the workshop
in uh out of the corner of my eye there
was a baseball card on the floor
and when i went to pick up that card it
was a
indiana jones trading card with a
picture of the little maharaja
so but it was like from
1984 or something like that or 1983
i don't quote me i know the years the
movies came out i don't know when the
cards were printed is what i'm saying
okay and so i picked it up and kept it
because i was like what a weird thing
that there's this perfectly
intact gem mentis the card fans would
say
a little maharaja card i i did a google
search to make sure it wasn't valuable
because otherwise i would have turned it
in
it was worthless it was like you know so
i kept it i put it in my wallet
and it was a source of good luck
for me uh i thought i would take it out
and like you know rub it for luck
uh when i was gambling at a casino or
talking to a girl that i
like you know i would be rubbing the
little maharaja like what are you
rubbing in your pocket tommy i would be
going like this i'd be like yes
they're like yeah why are your hands
just moving around your pocket so fast
no
i didn't do that necessarily but this
thing was a source of good luck for me
and then i
lost it oh no but there's a happy ending
to this
because it became kind of famous to my
friends because i would take it out and
like you know
i would whip it out and whip the little
maharaja out and kind of wave him around
at people
but i would like i'd say oh rub the
maharaja for good luck like rub the card
for good luck
my friend brian conawal uh as a joke
gift
got me the complete set of indiana jones
and the temple of doom trading cards
uh not knowing that i had lost the
little maharaja
so i replaced him i replaced the little
maharaja
wow tommy what a nice friend what a nice
gift
he is a great friend and a nice gift so
that would be that card to me is a totem
that that
that i would have uh it's a little good
luck charm for me what about you eric
you know i was uh i do have a real totem
real quick there
i used to have this uh remember when
welch's did a promotion of tom and jerry
glasses
oh yes uh i had one as a kid and it was
like my favorite thing and i for
whatever reason brought it with me to
college because i'm like i love drinking
little
juice out of this yeah and um i had this
uh desk in my dorm room that it had like
a retractable
um uh platform where you could put your
uh
keyboard on and i had rested uh we were
shooting the sketch in there with philip
uh he was shooting it and i was playing
a character and
we had to have oj so i was like i don't
know if i want to use this because it's
important to me
and he put it on the retractable thing
and he was sitting in a computer chair
and just
he always has to like anytime he sits
has to like lean back
and put his feet up in weird ways uh and
he leaned back
and it slid back the retractable thing
and it was one of these things for my
glasses on it and it just went it fell
and it shattered
and i was like and then he started
laughing
and i was like my welch is glass and i
think that's why he was laughing because
it was just so precious
but that wouldn't be my totem i just
want to tell a story about phillip
brooke oh but the reason
your story reminded me of it i was uh uh
dating a girl afterwards and as a gift
she got me a replacement glass oh that's
a nice
gift i've ever got yeah not a good
girlfriend to have but it was nice
oh but sometimes sometimes terrible
girlfriends are great gift givers i'll
say that
i had a girl i had a girlfriend like she
completely
re like styled my wardrobe like then
broke up with me like she took me
shopping
and like i bought a lot of the clothes
with my money but she bought me some
clothes too like she was just like i'm
gonna help you dress better
and she was right like it wasn't a mean
thing like i dressed like a
child i wore like basketball shorts and
tank tops everywhere which i like
yeah that's the thing no no relationship
is totally wasted uh there was a
girlfriend i had
who uh taught me a little trick of uh
your water bottles your big
water bottles like you can um put them
they usually don't fit in your car
cupholders but they will fit between the
door and your seat
and they lock in place and they don't
spill or roll around
and uh not a good girlfriend to have but
a great trick that i use all the time
so there's something to be learned in
every relationship you know
it's always useful to get yourself out
there and to date you never know
you know what i'm gonna get i'm gonna
i'm getting back on the apps eric you
just convinced me
um my totem would be when i was a kid
i had this um marble egg
that i got from a the science center
in atlanta and in the gift shop they
just had this
this black marble egg that i saw it and
i was obsessed with it
and i loved the weight of it it was like
heavy so i think like what totems are an
inception it has to be like a unique
thing that you know the weight and the
balance of
that means something to you and i
i keep talking about this i'm obsessed
with eggs um
i have this weird story philosophy
that i believe all the best stories are
uh based on eggs or based on the idea of
life in some way like um jj abrams has
this whole theory of the mystery box and
you can go find his ted talk where he
talks about how
as a kid he was obsessed with magic and
he
bought this uh box and he realized
the box itself was so ornately designed
and that if you the the promise of an
interesting story is so
powerful and that has defined his
storytelling philosophy and if you look
at things like
you know his star wars movies at lost
and mr possible three
star trek movies they all have really
exciting first
acts but then they never answer any of
their questions
right he's gonna leave it open-ended um
so my
egg theory is a distillation of jj
abrams mystery box theory i believe that
the egg is the same kind of idea right
it's a mystery box
but you know kind of what's inside
what's inside is the promise of life
and i think every good story does that
they
give you this kind of thematic promise
of something
and that at the end of the day a good
story
always affirms life in a way oh i love
it makes it you know
and every all my favorite movies all my
favorite books comic books
tv shows all do this so like jurassic
park that has a
symbolic power of an egg and life
finding a way a wall-e
eve is shaped like an egg and she gets
fertilized with that plant and that
becomes a symbolic uh
focus of the movie um watchmen on hbo
egg it's all about the egg um guardians
of the galaxy there's been theories
where it's like there's an egg there
uh godzilla there's egg like
everything's eggs and i'm obsessed with
eggs
and uh and so i feel like my totem would
have to be for you
perfect for you i'll write a book about
this i'll do a ted talk or a podcast
series about why eggs are everything
and my goal in life because every time i
pitch this to someone they're always
just like oh my god this guy's
weird and obsessed with birds and eggs
and i am but my goal is to when i pitch
a sister
to someone they don't start laughing in
my face that they're like
oh like i want everyone in the world to
appreciate eggs as much as i do
and i started with you yeah yes
i'm in position i think this oh i got
one
i got one i got it it's an that's one
shell of an
idea you crack me up oh
yes um well
on that note that is it for this episode
of big question
thank you to tommy for joining me this
episode you can follow tommy at tommy
bechtold
uh you can follow me at eavos follow the
rockstar send us your big questions
using the hashtag bigquestion
but really you're gonna want to join our
official new rockstars discord available
to all patrons
and put your questions there uh you can
subscribe to this podcast feed leave us
a nice reading review subscribe to
rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell
and another quick shout out to our
friends at stereo the app that lets
users listen in seek out topics and join
conversations about issues and ideas
that interest them like comedy pop
culture sports all kinds of topics
stereo can be downloaded for free by
apple and android users
once you download the app you can create
an avatar and profile and start going
live yourself
you can submit audio messages to the
host of conversations to join the
conversation in real time
we go live with our interactive new
rockstars news show
hosted by myself and philip molina on
wednesdays at 1pm pacific
you'll be able to hear that on stereo
and you can submit your theories and
reactions your personal grooming tips on
there
we do this every monday wednesday and
friday just go to stereo dot com slash
new rock starts to get all the details
and get notified when we're going live
again that's stereo dot com
new rockstars see you next time tommy
[Music]
you